that's right it has just been confirmed
in the last couple of moments that Her
Majesty the Queen has recorded a special
broadcast which will be broadcast to the
United Kingdom and the Commonwealth in
relation to the corona virus outbreak
the televised address is going to be
broadcast at eight o'clock on Sunday
night so just to confirm we now know
that the Queen has recorded a special
broadcast we know that she's currently
spending time at Windsor Castle she
always would spend time at Windsor at
this time of year during Easter court
but we know that she went there a week
early due to the corona virus and
because the precautions are being taken
to make sure that Her Majesty stays safe
so that message was recorded at Windsor
Castle and is now going to be broadcast
on Sunday night at 8 o'clock now this is
a very significant development I think
many people have been wondering when
exactly we were going to hear from Her
Majesty the Queen about the corona virus
outbreak not just as head of state but
also through that symbolic role of head
of nation which she also embodies so
when it comes to big moments of yes in a
national celebration but also moments of
national tragedy throughout her 68 year
reign she has always been for many
people that symbol of stability of
continuity and it's always been
important that she has been seen to be
talking to the people of this country
also her subjects right across the wider
Commonwealth she's often been seen as
that steadying force through great
moments really of social political and
economic change and most recently 10
days ago she issued her own written
address in which she talked about these
being incredibly challenging time so it
was always going to be interesting to
see when exactly the palace and also the
government decided was the best moment
for her to decide to speak to the nation
through a televised address they clearly
decided that now is the best moment it
is also worth pointing out that these
televised addresses by Her Majesty the
Queen are incredibly rare yes every year
we are used to hearing her addressing
the country addressing the wider
Commonwealth
through her Christmas Day message but in
terms of these televised addresses for
other other reasons simply they have
only been around three that I can think
of the death of Princess Diana the death
of the Queen Mother and also during the
Gulf War so just to confirm it has just
been announced by Buckingham Palace that
Her Majesty the Queen has recorded a
special broadcast which be shown here in
the United Kingdom and across the
Commonwealth in relation to the corona
virus outbreak and that we televised on
Sunday night at eight o'clock